we're delighted to bring you the seminar
presented by lab roots and in
collaboration with the National
Institute of Health welcome to our track
on the NIH brain initiative a
multidisciplinary approach to
neuroscience we're glad you can join us
through this panel presentation titled
sensory motor processing decision-making
internal States towards a realistic
multi scale circuit model of the larval
zebrafish brain it's my pleasure to
introduce to you a panel of experts who
will be speaking on the topic of
understanding circuits and behavior for
a full listing please click on the tab
at the top of your screen if any
questions should arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them into the Q&A box our speakers will
respond back to you via email and as a
reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
please join me in welcoming our panel of
experts hello my name is Lillian Inga
and I'm a member of team in the context
of the NIH new 19 grants that are trying
to find out how the brain of a novel
signal fish gives rise to adaptive
behavior so as you can see the title of
our presentation is sensory motor
housing decision-making an internal
stage for what's a realistic multi scale
circuit model of the loved zebrafish
brain in short what we're trying to find
out how the brain of this animal the
neural circuitry gives rise to that
behavior to gain an understanding of
that and I probably should introduce the
zebrafish as a model system in settings
neuroscience and the next slide here
illustrates the power but was the
challenge that this animal provides and
it is tiny it's only about four
millimeters in length a millimeter
across and it is perfectly translucent
so it allows us to in principle which
neural activity throughout the brain of
awake and behaving animal on the left
you see a still shot of neural activity
measured across the brain in the center
is a top-down view on the top is a
side-on view on the left is a head-on
view across novelty Blowfish
on the right you'll see a still shot of
the anatomical reconstruction of a
subset of the neurons and what will
convince you over the course of the
whole presentation is that we can
actually combine these two technologies
in the same animal and we will now show
a video when you first see the activity
patterns across the brain as you see on
the left and it will follow with a
visualization of the 3d structure of
some of these neurons and I'll start the
movie now and allow you to appreciate
the beauty and complexity of life pain
in action please let's go let's go let's
get going with the movie
you
you could appreciate the complexity and
the beauty in those two images for the
record I should point out that these two
movies have been taken in separate
animals but the whole purpose of our
collaboration here is to allow us in the
future to combine and brain wide imaging
is shown in the first part with brain
wide connectomics ie the wiring patterns
of the neurons that give rise to this
activity in the same animal
this is will be in more detail how we
gonna do this will be in detail
discussed in the and down the road um in
the next slide it's posed the central
question what are we gonna do with all
of these data these are terabytes and
petabytes of data and how are we gonna
use each data to gain insight about what
the brain is actually doing and why mmm
it's doing what it's doing so I think
it's important to point out that just
description of the activity is not
really an explanation of how the brain
works so to briefly outline how we will
connect data to to brain function I want
to briefly give credit to David Moore
and he surrended in young scientists who
died I think in 1981 but one of the
pioneers in thinking about brains and he
allowed us to pose the question more in
more detail what does it mean to
actually understand the brain so the way
he phrased it is any machine carrying
out an information processing task must
be understood at the following three
levels and the three levels of
understanding the brain as posited by
David Marr are the following the first
question you have to answer is why is
people in doing what it is the one and
what is the goal of the computation why
is it appropriate and what is the logic
of this package
by which it can be carried out or in
other words what good does it do for the
animal mostly in an evolutionary
perspective the second level of
understanding according to David Marsh
and the what what's the algorithm
what's the representation and of the
computation or in other words how can
this computational theory be implemented
in particular what is the representation
for the input and output modesty
algorithm for the transformation and
only lastly and once we have an idea of
those two thirst and bullet points I
think that it really makes sense to
engage more deeply in the how
namely what is the hardware
implementation how can the
representation and algorithm be realized
physically so this is sort of the large
line of thinking along which we have
organized our whole project here are the
three levels of understanding by David
Marr I think we are trying to get sort
of a handle on all three of them and so
it's really important if you've probably
gathered it's behavioral algorithms what
are exactly the behaviors that allow
zebrafish can do so that's one of the
challenges that we have addressed in the
last ten years and this is illustrated
here in their slide where and we've
outlined and depicted in cartoon form
and five of adaptive important behaviors
that a lot of zebrafish and has to
execute in a natural environment
the first is T of the motor reflex which
I will discuss in more detail in the
next slides which basically and says the
Dalaran zebrafish when confronted with
whole field moving stimuli will swim to
follow along with the stimulus the next
is real taxes
meaning if the fish is in a river or in
a moving stream of water it will
generally tends to swim against the
current and presumably in order to stay
as its position in a moving stream and
thus phototaxis fish will swim towards
the light when given a choice between
light and dark and that's probably
useful because they're highly visual
animals and they like to be in
where they can see where they can use
vision the final two behaviors hunting
and escape are obvious in terms of my
little one why is this useful for the
animal and these are also behaviors that
the planning to analyze in more detail I
will for the purpose of this
presentation focus on the first the
optimal response and real taxes I will
discuss in more detail and the optimal
response the first and then - Polinsky
and the member of Shaham will then tell
us a little bit more deeply into the
problem of real taxes let me first
discuss the orlimar the optimal response
and in a little bit of detail yet so am
as i said already it's a fish will swim
along with a whole field moving stimulus
and this is shown in this little gift
and so there's a fish swimming on a
normal pattern background when the
padlock that background starts to move
the fish will all turn and swim along
with it this is a real fish swimming
along and the way you can think about
this is that not the background is
moving to the left but maybe the fish is
being Specht to the right and therefore
again this is just an attempt of the
animal to stabilize its position in a
moving stream this can be discussed at
two levels first my level 1 why is this
useful for an animal and maybe it's
useful because it allows them to stay in
the region where the parents have laid
the eggs so maybe that is a useful and
adaptive favorable position for a level
zebrafish and if they're being swept
along they are just trying to contact
his this movement and to analyze this
behavior so to get to my little - in
more detail we are using a trick which
is called a closed-loop
behavioral analysis where we monitor the
fish with a camera and we will update
the stimulus in closed-loop according to
the position and the orientation of the
animal what this allows us to do is
expose the fish to a left foot moving
stimulus and when the fish is water
turning to change its direction as shown
in this animation the stimulus is locked
by the feedback loop to the fish such
that there's always left foot stimulus
no matter what the fish is doing this is
frustrating for the animal because it
can't really and escape this condition
where and the stimulus is always moving
to the left but it allows us to really
collect now and a large set of data
under these very well defined conditions
here is a movie where this is happening
in real life now so the stimulus is
always moving to the left of the dish
fish is trying to align itself with the
orientation of the motion and again we
can run this for many many hours and
collect millions of individuals in pouch
that allow us to dissect in great detail
what exactly the algorithm is what's the
nature of the input what's the nature of
the output and what is the algorithm
that connects it him then Kumaresh will
later give a brief description of a
project where we will stimulate the two
eyes of the fish with different motion
and see how they integrate how the
animals integrate at the behavioral
level stimuli that might be in conflict
with each other here is another example
of a behavior in this case it's real
taxes we're not their visual stimulus is
moving but the water is moving around at
the animal so once the movie gets
started not quite yet
when you will see is that there's flow
coming from the right which has pump
waters on this tube and what you'll see
is that the fish will start and swimming
and orienting itself against the stream
there will be two elements to the movie
one where the fish has visual
information as well when the light is
switched on in the second part of the
movie the second file is where we switch
off the light and you'll see that the
fish still can orient against us which
tells us that these phenols can do this
also in the absence of visual
stimulation which opens the opportunity
to study a completely different
not the visual modality but this motor
sensory modality but now I let you enjoy
this movie so if you can run the movie
now first with line and then without
lamplight please go
you
the visual input to execute this
behavior which really opens the
fascinating question is what sensory
modality are they using and more
interestingly even what is the exact
algorithm that they're using to execute
this behavior and Nimrod later on will
tell you too much more details about
this so maybe I've given you a brief
flavor of what the whole project is
about I've discussed the three levels of
them David Marr and the technological
approaches we have we can do imaging is
shown on the upper left
meaning calcium imaging of brain bite
activity we can image the whole animal
and then the readout of the behavior as
I've said already we will we are
collaborating with with a group that is
also focusing on the theory so we can
use Siri to extract the behavioral
algorithms and that also will inform the
circuit theory and that allows us to
think about how the neural networks that
make up the zebrafish is playing give
rise to the behavior and finally we can
use connectomics so en paged anatomy and
to check validate constrain and explore
the circuits further that are being
proposed and put forward based on brain
wide imaging of the neurons and Fahim of
theory and here are the two team leaders
on the top is Florian anga bottom right
- Polinski and then the chief lachemann
and i think it is really a beautiful
example of a collaborative enterprise
where different expertise is complement
each other in a very productive and
meaningful way so mar 11 one would be
mostly the behavior allows us to
speculate about the evolutionary reasons
why this behavior arises small level two
is best addressed with behavioral theory
whereas the other technologies allow us
to an dissect in detail the
implementation at the neural circuit
level and the whole team is much more
than just the 3p is I think we mostly
and applaud and the maybe occasionally
direct but it is a large-scale
enterprise and that we believe is
necessary to combine all of these and
different technologies the three aims we
are trying to address in the project is
first to find a holistic theory that
includes behavioral algorithms network
implementation for these five and
behavioral and modules that I've
described in some detail and aim to is
to ask what happens if the fish is
exposed to conflicting or parallel and
sensory stimuli in the real world loved
zebrafish do not have to Amamiya don't
have the luxury of dealing with Omar for
the taxes hunting and looming predator
avoidance in sequence they usually have
to deal with a multitude of sensory
stink eye that bombard the fish in
parallel so aim to is of our project is
to find out what happens if the animal
has to is exposed to conflicting stimuli
name three is the question how these
sensory motor transformations and
decision-making processes that we're
describing here and how all of these
prostitutes are influenced and by
internal States and meaning if the fish
is hungry if it's fired is expressed if
it's in danger if it's lonely there are
many neuroendocrine and your modular
Tory processes that puts the animal into
different than internal states and we
want to know how these internal states
his law dynamics modulate the fast
processes that we are describing name
one and two so it's not just the outer
first sensory motor process the outer
brain that we're interested in we are
also interested in the inner brain that
reflects the internal state with that
I'll finish my presentation and I will
hand over to find some Polinski who will
lead you to our religion through our
efforts of trying to get a theory
an algorithmic em concept of all of
these hello my name is crimestop Olinsky
I'm a theoretical neuroscientist
participating in the zebrafish
do9 thinking oh nice to build
computational models and mathematical
theories of the behavior and the
underlying neural circuits in order to
uncover my principles underlying sensory
motor functions the first project is
about optimal response the tendency of
the animal to stabilize itself with
respect to its visual environment in the
first phase of our collaborations we
have constructed a draft bring my Joseph
model of the animal as you can see in
the top right of the slide this however
is a coarse-grained model describing the
interaction between large groups of
neurons to develop a high-resolution one
circuit model we need to challenge the
animal and his brain with complex visual
motion cues he will focus on scenarios
where the two eyes receive conflicting
motion cues we asked first what is the
third the fish strategy to resolve such
conflict and second what are the neural
mechanisms that implement such
strategies ongoing efforts to address
these questions will be described by
Kumaresh Krishnan
a talented PhD students engaging both
experiment and computational modeling of
the umma hi I'm Connor age Krishnan
and I'll be talking to you how we are
focusing on integrating information from
both eyes in the context of the Omar
behavior and larval zebrafish
so how do we target each eye
independently we want a way to provide a
different motion cue to each eye and as
you can see in this picture over here
the zebrafish
can be stimulated with different
directions of motion each eye and they
will carry out the optimal response and
give us a sense of what they think is
the direction of whole film motion this
gives us a sign
of how they're able to integrate
information from both eyes now the
question is how do we cover all the
different directions and in order to do
that we can sample the entire stimulus
space into eight different directions
and we present all combinations of these
directions to both eyes so through this
experimental effort what we want to
address is how the left and right
responses are able to combine to form
the whole response how does the
zebrafish
respond to motion cues and denies well
they turn with a specific angle in
response to different stimuli over here
I show you one example where the two
angles of motion seen in each eye are
represented by the arrows on top and the
plot as such shows the distribution of
turns made by the liver zebrafish as you
can see there are a large number of
forward turns which we expect because
the zebrafish wants to move and in
addition there are these two side peaks
on the left and right which indicate the
instances where the zebrafish
turns so we look at these distribution
of turns as the response to all these
stimuli and we go ahead to try and build
models of this I will show you another
case where the zebrafish is responding
to a stimulus where there is only
rightward motion and you can see in
addition to the central peak where the
forward swims are high there is also an
increased rightward swim frequency and
this is what you would expect when the
stimulus is more backward in googley
stimuli you can see that the left eye
sees only rightward motion but simply
changing the direction of motion seen
and the right eye was able to produce
such a big change in the response so
essentially what you're captured here is
the likelihood of the zebrafish turning
with a specific angle how can we proceed
to model something like this well we
make use of the observation that there
are three components to the response a
forward component a leftward component
and a rightward component and we try to
use this in the context of
we call the Gaussian mixture model to
model this behavior so the basis of this
model is that each of these components
can be characterized by a Gaussian
distribution and these three gaussians
correspond to the left right and the
center are combined with different
weights so the three different
components are able to be represented as
Gaskins and this is an example of how
our model represents these stimuli this
is the same example that I've shown on
the previous slide where there are
conflicting motion cues in each eye and
as you can see the orange line here
shows how our model is able to
accurately capture the response of the
zebrafish you can see that the former
swim is captured and the two side piece
that correspond to the left and right
turns are also captured so in a sense
each gaussian is modulated by
corresponding weight and they all are
referring to the turning capability of
the zebrafish in a forward leftward or
rightward what I want you to note here
is that this is just a likelihood of
turning essentially a probability
distribution this loses out any
information about what the overall
response to the stimulus was in order to
address this we need to have a scale
factor for each of these responses that
can kind of serve as a way to denote the
overall response rate of the zebrafish I
will show you one mathematical equation
which is basically what the entire
modeling effort is the first term R of
theta L theta R refers to the response
rate this is a measure of how the
zebrafish responds to different stimuli
a different stimuli being an angle shown
in the left eye theta L and an angle
shown in the right eye theta R and this
will be able to scale all the
probability distributions that we model
and how do we model the probability
distributions there are three gaussians
each with their own means mu and their
variances Sigma Square and there are
three gaussians here one for the left
one for the center
one for the right and all of them are
combined with these wigs WL WC and WI
since we want them to be a probability
distribution the only other constraint
that is imposed over here is that the
weights up to one this is in a sense the
entire mathematics behind the model now
given that we were able to model the
behavior so well how do the weights or
let's say even the response rate are
vary across the stimuli let's take a
look at that now
this picture shows you how the response
rate or the overall response rate of the
zebrafish varies with different angle is
shown in the right and left eye as you
can see the central portion of this
surface corresponding to zero comma zero
is where the response is maximum and
this dies down as a simulus becomes more
backward or the points marked by 180 180
and this is what you would expect on the
right I'm showing you the variation of
the right weight of the Gaussian what
can we observe over here the peak of the
surface is occurring at more rightward
stimuli which correspond to a 90 degree
direction shown in each eye and the way
the right weight dies down when there is
more leftward stimulus and these trends
are what you would expect and real-life
as you as the stimulus is more rightward
the right weight will increase and as
the stimulus tends toward left for the
component this weight component will
decrease what can be then build a
mathematical representation of these
surfaces so that we can then
characterize the entire automotive
response across the binocular space and
so initially we saw we thought out how
to build a model for integration of
information from both eyes so we had the
behavioral aspect where so directed
motion cues to both eyes at the same
time we will be able to conduct
experiments where we show directed
motion cues to only a single eye and see
how these combine at the behavior of
model
we can see how this binocular motion
model that we just described can be
broken down into the individual
components where we only look at the
model for the stimulus presented in the
left eye or the stimulus presented in
the right eye and then again at the
neural circuit level we can see whether
the response is generated by the last
portion of burning and can be combined
with the response is generated from the
right portion and combine to form the
overall responses so essentially in all
these levels we're trying to address the
question how do they combine and this
size isn't pretty well with the three
level of the David Martha Florian tuck
but earlier and this is how we go ahead
to address information integration from
both eyes in the context that we have
the water response the next
computational model addresses a little
taxes a slow yawn beautifully explained
when the animal is in a stream the fish
tends to orient itself against the flow
direction to stabilize its position his
function that require visual input in
the dart it uses tactile sensors the new
masks in the natural nine system our
research questions are to first what is
the null basis from your tuchis behavior
at the moment we know relatively little
about underline neural circuits what we
are particularly interested is to find
out specific Network motifs that will
characterize neural circles under Lionel
taxes and to use these motifs to look in
the connectomics of the fish to find out
the relevant known circles that exhibit
those motifs the regards to the fish
behavior as you will see in a moment
this function is relatively challenging
and the fish doesn't always accomplish
the goal so in us is the Fisher touches
response optimal and if not if there are
algorithms mathematical or computer
algorithms that can do better
fish we would like to know what are the
constraints that lead to the observable
suboptimal behavior the ones are
interested to know whether the fish
shows adaptive behavior in real taxes
and can we design new experiments to
find out the extent of adaptive features
of your taxes these features will be
described in a moment by Nemo chaja
anomalies a talented young aspiring
theoretical no scientist with a
postdoctoral research fellow develops
models of both the behavior and the
lower algorithms underlying the taxes
function in the fish okay so as Hine
described it is a challenging behavior
to achieve the real Ted and then call
for your taxes which is there not to get
carried away by string even without the
visual bear information so here I will
describe in a behavioral algorithm or
policy that Fisher might be using in
order to perform this behavior and then
I'll try to describe as near incipit
that they can be underlying this behave
so first importantly using the new masks
the fish the fish might be able to
detect a rotational flow around itself
which is characterized by a column
matically
object that measures how much rotation
there is in the flow and when a fish is
found in the stream that is not uniform
meaning that there is some slope or a
gradient in the in the velocity feeling
then the fish will will feel this kind
of rotational flow
solitaire or the rotation or the curling
of the flow is a measure of the gradient
or the change the special change of the
velocity field so that the behavioral
algorithm ragosa's for the fish measured
the gradient in two consecutive
locations one before about and one
and it checks there the magnitude of the
Grady if the gradient in increasing the
finisher will bias the next boat to be
in the direction of rotation meaning the
clockwise or counterclockwise while if
the gradient decreases the official they
generate an island by a spell centered
around rates their current direction and
this kind of behavioral algorithm may
give rise to add behavior that they we
actually see in the fish which is a
swimming air towards the center of the
eye when and and and the fish orient
itself against the flow and so now we
can ask ourselves what kind of fan you
will network will they can generate it's
kind of algorithmic so here is our
suggestion suggestion we are suggesting
at the following gate circuit as you've
seen the left picture you have read
those are units with which inputs from
the neural Nets in about the size of the
fish are one mer unit will be active
when the fish feels a counter clockwise
the rotational rate and also will be
active when the fish feels a clockwise
Dutchman flow so the other serve as a
current detectors and they can measure
the current a colonel in air so the the
gradient and then this information is
sent to the m units with which they're
going to mix them to make the decision
of fair or better to a bias or not to
base the following but this information
goes through a tank only a derivative
suit which is a computer of the genius
doesn't have a different time scale what
one is the inhibitory air you need slow
tanks in and the other one is excitatory
with faster types and those units
integrate the information from the
current detector from our and they will
let us set the information to the M unit
which will be affected by whether the
increased or decreased if gradient was
increased MDM unit will tend to make a
decision too biased about in the
direction of the rotational spin and if
the the gradient decreased the next out
one here but yeah as you can see here
this kind of a model when we simulate it
we simulate the fish behavior using this
network generates the very similar a
statistics of paths to water we see in
the real fish area you need to have to
see data from real fish the blue curves
rara the statistic of statistics of
bounce when you don't have a gradient
decrease which are quite vexing metric
and in red you see the statistics of
paths where after an increase in
gradient and you see that there is a
pump in some positive direction in the
direction of the tension this is the
bias that the in addition we can look at
the fish trajectories a simulated fish
trajectories and there you can see in
there in the top panel that the X
location of the fish which is the
perpendicular direction of the flow
tends to coordinate the fish tends to go
to the center of the floor two x equals
zero and the direction of the fish
relative to the flow tends to work to a
PI or PI radians or Honda under the 98
degrees which is a instrument itself
against the flow so it is so this is to
show that the simulated fish does they
perform the behavior I expected there
it's a shower shown a very fish and now
it will be interesting to check whether
we can find out this kind of motifs
those at the span of the inhibition
circuit includes the excitation and
inhibition and they're done by different
units in the plane and then these kind
of relatives will be looking for in
electron microscopy
next say I want to play address the
optimality of the real taxes behavior
from the algorithm I described a you get
to interesting consequences well in the
regular flow in a in a stream as in the
top panel view the features we said tend
to go to the center of the of the time
an orient itself against the stream this
is the correct direction to be in where
you if you don't want to get the money
but it's the wrong location because this
is where the stream velocity is maximum
on the other end if we can invert the
velocity profile so that the maximum
velocity is on the on the salad then the
algorithm will take the fish towards the
center of the stream which is the right
location because there are the
velocities I mean well but it will be in
the wrong direction because now the face
for the Perot the fish will face the
direction of the flow so we can ask
ourselves whether the fish can do better
given the inputs it gets the gradient of
the flow measured in the two consecutive
fences when the fish do better than that
they may not get carried away by stream
in other traders this is a question we a
model the fish the fish emotion as a
dynamical system and here you see we use
X as the location of the fish
perpendicular to the string Z as the
fish location in the direction of the
stream and theta angle and then the
orientation of the fish compared to the
stream and you know we modernly say this
policy the decision-making of the fish
by this function f that gets a two
inputs the grant the current gradient
and the gradient in the one time step
there before and it will generate the
purpose of the turn whether the turn
will be a what what will be the average
direction of the next day next stop and
now we would like to see what the
function f will be optimal to achieve
where the the least amount of area of
the carried away getting carried away by
this
there in order to optimize this we use a
thick neural network where to a model is
a function in the bias traction this is
a modern modern approach used quite a
lot now in the machine learning in the
area research and we are optimizing this
function f2 against the minimal amount
of a of drift by the stream in the
results as you see here the optimal a
dip neural network function does there
pretty similarly today today official
written despite that earlier meaning
that the fish circuit carried a
algorithmic fish get so carried away
quite similarly to what the network
could not sense and also the behavior is
quite similar and and interestingly the
how well the fish can do is restricted
to a range of velocities of the string
which is a point that that we would like
to be able to test in the in future
experiments what if we push the fishing
to regimes of higher velocities than
what they what E is you can handle or if
we use interest different interesting
air profiles and CA our similar or
different fish does compared to our a
model deep neural network okay so to
summarize we showed that the way we
propose a neural circuit model we can
underlie your taxes behavior and we
would like to see if the motives that we
see it there can be a measured in
electron microscopy an in addition we
use the neural network to find an
optimal policy of for the fish to
achieve a minimal drift in the stream
and we want to validate it by
experimentally by behavioral experiments
and network to get out of those another
some limitations on what the fish can or
cannot do and then test them again in
any
thank you
the next speaker will be a Jeff Lichtman
I was the the head of the electron
microscopy a research done on the
zebrafish and he will describe the
research done in that direction my name
is Jeff Lichtman and I'm going to
describe for you the automated I should
say mostly automated connectomics
approach we take with serial electron
microscopy we've developed a pipeline to
generate a wiring diagram of the larval
zebrafish and this gets to that third
level of Marv where we're getting to the
actual implementation in the neural
circuits I want to talk a little bit
about this pipeline because although
it's it's a technical problem of
generating this wiring diagram it's
taken a great deal of time to do and so
I thought it would be useful maybe to
emphasize some aspects of this the first
is that there are many technologically
challenging steps to get something to
work on the scale of a whole fish and
these steps are not the same it's not
that you have to solve one problem you
have to solve many different problems
and every one of these steps are still
under continuous scrutiny to improve
their reliability and their speed all of
them could be more reliable and all of
them could be faster and speed and
reliability are the essential
ingredients of the successful pipeline
third over it's nice to know that over
the course of this nineteen we have by
necessity actually changed enough things
to seeing dramatic improvements in both
the throughput and the consistency of
our results
we're very grateful for that it gives us
confidence that what seems heroic will
soon seem routine it's not yet routine
but we don't eventually this will be
truly routine to do this kind of work
and I hope you'll agree that we've made
good progress in generating a full
resolution fish connectome so let me
talk a little bit about the pipeline
pipeline is a kind of funny term but it
means that we're passing the fish from
one procedure to another and ultimately
we get rid of the fish and then we deal
with the digital data and that is what
carries us all the way to the finish
line which would be a complete analysis
I guess of the wiring diagram of an
animal I'm gonna go through the many
steps of this pipeline somewhat briefly
but just to give you a sense of how many
things have to work in order to get the
fish wiring guy start with we don't just
take a fish right out of an aquarium or
out of a river we take a fish that is
often already a transgenic animal that
expresses either calcium indicators or
perhaps labels molecular labels that
give us some insight into the fish and
that are visualized either by two-photon
microscopy or confocal microscopy the
fish that we've been working on and that
we will describe in detail for you in
the next 15 minutes or so is a fish
where the information was not activity
information but functional information
of a different sort
we divided the fish and the cells that
are excitatory in cells that are
inhibitory and those were imaged with a
confocal microscope the living fish was
imaged that way and those sets of cells
were labeled different colors and that's
officially are much more about that for
Mariella who will speak after me that's
the fish that we went on
working on its connectome so first we
have a fish then we have to preserve the
fish and that first step in preservation
it's to fix it to put aldehydes in there
to basically harden it and stabilize the
structure that's not as trivial as just
dunk dunking the fish in fixative
doesn't fix it it won't go through the
skin so a great deal of effort has gone
into making good fixation by making a
narrow slit in the fish to expose parts
of the animal to fixative that would
otherwise be protected from it by the
skin and then following the fixation
step you then have to mentalize the fish
store in every single membrane into
something that's visible in an electron
microscope and that requires staining
the fish with heavy metals in particular
osmium which is a very good electron
microscopy signal but again and it's not
trivial to get a fish ozma cated to the
point where all the cells are well
labeled after the labeling up then we
have to infiltrate the fish with a heavy
hard resin resin that's very hard which
would allow us now to slice the fish in
very thin sections without having it to
crumble so resin and filtration is the
next step and we trim that block and
then in some fish now it's de rigueur to
do this but in this first element we
haven't done this but I'm just going to
mention this because it's now part of
the pipeline we image the entire fish in
a micro CT machine a computerized
tomography machine using x-rays that
gives us cellular level resolution of
all the cells of the nervous system in
fact all the cells in the body in
addition it tells us whether the stain
was successful and it provides a very
nice intermediate point between the
optical imaging that was done with a
confocal or two photon and the ultimate
electron microscopy imaging which is
done after the sectioning so it's a nice
point for
thing to be aligned to the micro CT
image once we feel the [ __ ] is useful
and it's worth going on we then cut the
block into many many thin sections we
use a automatic collecting ultra
microtome that's what autumn stands for
which basically means we're cutting the
fish very thin 30 nanometer sections and
picking these sections up on a tape that
collects all of the animal in one
section at a time so we take a
three-dimensional fish and linearize it
into a bunch of little sections and then
those sections are put on tape and that
tank ends up on reels and then the tank
is cut into strips and those strips are
pasted on to silicon wafers that are
very flat and you can see in that middle
picture a series of strips with little
raised spots on them each of those spots
is a separate section and those wafers
are what ultimately will be imaged in
the electron microscope but before
imaging a wafer and I try microscope we
have to decide where the sections are on
those wafers because it would waste a
lot of electron microscopy time hunting
around for each session so we then do
another kind of imaging we take the
wafer and the stage holder and we image
it with a reflected light optical
microscope to localize every single
section on each wafer and then we have
what we call it is a mapped wafer where
each section is position is known and
then that plus the stage holder is put
into a remarkable new machine a multi
beam scanning electron microscope that
was designed actually for connectomics
for this project the first one ever is
in our laboratory that is what you see a
picture of it there it's a very fast
machine that's designed for rapid
imaging of large volumes by fast imaging
of session after section with a multi
beam of I'll say a little bit more
that and in order to make the multi-beam
a super-efficient which it wasn't when
we first got it we built a workflow
manager that allows us to in real time
make sure it's taking images of high
quality and also providing us with
thumbnails smaller images of the whole
data set that are more tractable than
the three hundred and fifty terabytes
this data set is all together that we
can use for alignment and you'll see a
lot of those images coming up and then
we can register those thumbnails which
have cellular resolution oh the electron
might be the optical microscopy you'll
hear Mariola talk about that so I won't
go into much detail about that and at
the same time we do a full resolutions
chicken alignment which is
computationally intense and then with
that we can then generate a full
resolution data around truth you can
trace out every single wire in a small
volume and do that in several different
volumes and that provides information
for machine learning algorithms that
allow a team in this case Google to
segment the whole the fish every single
wire being figured out just based on a
small amount of ground truth and so
ultimately we have two kinds of data we
have the functional data and the
segmentation data and of course we have
all the theory and expectations based on
three to allow us to do some kind of
circuit description and related to an
analysis to validate or test or
constrain theories that have been coming
so I just want to briefly mention a few
things about the fish in particular the
first is that the sectioning of a whole
fish is a lot of sections 30 nanometers
is a thousand first thing as a human
hair so you can imagine you have to cut
a lot of sections and indeed this
seven-day post fertilization larval
was first trimmed and cut in a
longitudinal direction that is the
sections were cut so from the detail
each section and nicely symmetrical left
at night side and we collected 17,500
sections the 30 nanometers Richard
shellac did most of the cutting and his
part of the team here really amazingly
good at doing this kind of cutting and
then that is a picture of the fish there
the dotted line on the bottom and the
dotted line to the right is what wasn't
cut but everything else was cut and that
generated three reels of tape with
sections on it and now those tape have
all been turned into wafers and on the
top of this image here you see that a
whole zebrafish brain has been turned
into a bunch of petri dishes 89 wafers
with 5005 sections and on the bottom is
the part of the fish that it's now been
put upon two sections now we have an
image all those sections at this point
at this point we've only imaged 6570
nine contiguous sections on 48 whimpers
but that is the part that is mostly
nervous system 80% of the CNS is in
those 48 wafers which are each shown
there and that total is about 200
microns depth and all of them have been
mapped because I've described an image
data in the multi beam electron
microscope at four by four nanometers in
the lateral and in each section is 30
nanometers thank so four by four by 30
nanometers or 480 cubic nanometers which
is a very small box'll though and that
generated 350 terabytes
so the multi beam I just want to say one
or two words about it because such an
interesting invention and it has
certainly helped a lot of comfortable a
lot of connectomics moving forward it's
a high throughput machine because
instead of putting one scanning beam in
at 61 beams
anning and proud in parallel
and the 61 beams generate a multi beam
field of interest basically these m5s
are 61 beams and arranged in the
hexagonal wetting and so if you have a
bunch of them together you can generate
by tiling a very large area
each damaged section is somewhere
between 50 and hundred gigabytes
depending on how much brain is in that
section and we generally for one section
somewhere between 100 and 200 of these
Emma files have to be stitched together
here's shown a 7m v stitch together and
that generates something that's about
300 microns by 300 microns each of these
m5s is a hexagon as I've mentioned those
are the 61 beams and it's about the half
a gigabyte and each one is made up of 61
stitch tiles that are visible there and
that generates about 100 microns of data
sync simultaneously so that's the unit
of image capture that a field of view
multiple scanning field of view and each
of the tiles in there is about eight and
a half megabytes 3d by 3000 by 2700
thanks also they're still very big
images each tile is a pretty big image
but this whole imaging adventure so far
has generated 40 million such tiles and
here's what one of those tiles look like
and they are looking up to see synaptic
vesicles so they're very high resolution
one other thing the last thing I want to
say is that to get through the data if
you have to do something 40 million
times it doesn't it doesn't mean every
single time it works so you have to have
some way to manage the data coming
through and this we've gotten high
through but thanks to working on whoa
another member of the team has done
making a real-time em some workflow
manager which
image quality with numerous checks
validating the files it also includes
spreadsheets and color-coded tiles that
itemize the quality of every child an
easy clickable access of any data that
needs scrutiny this picture you're
seeing for example has a pinkish area
which has no interesting data in it at
all it's actually just resin and that's
why it's pink because there's nothing in
focus there because there's nothing to
see the areas that are green are areas
that have high density of membranes and
any place that is not green but should
we breathe we can click on and see
whether it's because there's a staining
artifact or the mission was not focused
if we have to retake it
and these finally and generates aligned
thumbnails of the data which are really
valuable as you'll see Bill in Foley so
I'm gonna hand the reins over to Mariela
Toa who actually has masterminded this
entire workflow of the fish that we have
gotten through the pipeline thanks to
her and it'll give you a sense of how
far we've gotten to get high and I'm
here to help you visualize how we're
going to go from comic comics to
actually testing circuits would you see
on your screen right now are two
rotating brains and in those brains I
have labeled the sensory input and the
motor outputs from fish who is really
exciting about doing connectomics and
whole animal is that we can actually see
where the signals are coming from and
where they're going and our job is to
basically connect the dots on the left
you see the sensory input from the OMR
of the motor response if you see in cyan
the two optic nerves which come from the
ice and they were authorizing the brain
and those are making connections which
we can see if the connections they make
match what the model predicts
in green you see two very big neurons
those are called amount of neurons there
are the motor command neurons and
basically send motor signals and
activate the the movements of the fish
of course they don't act a lot there are
quite a few
Neuros but this is mostly the motor
center for fish on the right you see the
view Texas sensory inputs dr. the so
called Efrain platter online neurons
they send signals from the tail from
neon sensor in your mass along the tail
all the way to the brain and in the next
slide I will focus on the very first
time apps but these neurons make in the
brain so what is he here on the right
are the two lateral line afferent
neurons there being shades of blue they
are dr. yaks also dates and information
from the tail to the brain and we can
see the very first time lapses that they
make with with dendrites in the central
nervous system those central nervous
system neurons are shown in purple and
pink and just based on the connectivity
but we can see for instance the pink
neuron really helps this dark blue
neuron i frank axon and it makes
multiple recurrent connections with this
exam what this tells us is that there is
a very strong connection between those
two neurons if you take a look at the
purple neuron on the other hand that
neuron connects with both the light blue
and the dark blue lateral line afferent
it means that it's receiving signals
from both neurons that is basically a
way to integrate the signals that come
from those neurons what you see here are
3d structures and those 3d structures
are come from actual microscopy data in
the next movie I next slide I will show
you a movie of the whole fish I have
labeled for you the larger information
structures and in one instance you will
see a high-resolution image of all axles
and dendrites that are inside the very
small portion of that high resolution
image so let's take a look
you
would you just stop in the upper right
corner was inset which probably look to
you like a hopeless tangle of membranes
and neurons and you couldn't tell it
apart here I'm showing you something
similar which is a little bit easy for
you to distinguish on the left side is
the roll on colored images from the UM
theater in very dark you see the
membrane stained and in the very big
dark circles that you see are myelin
actually stain neurons on the left side
we have color than the each object
individually and you can already imagine
what this structure looks like in 3d I'm
guessing that you already can see that
you are literally sliding down a bundle
of neurons and I can show you this
structure and it's 3d shape so color in
this little box which is four by four by
eight nano microns it took us about 200
hours now the whole it is way bigger and
you can take more than a lifetime for
human to color and every single object
so instead mentioned we are training
machine learning algorithms in order to
to color the pictures for us in the way
that we have done this is we traced and
colored in six boxes from different
places in the fish as you can see just
by looking at the objects they're very
different regions and they have very
different ways of looking and we use
those six boxes to teach the computer
how to color and for us next we show the
computers just blank canvases that they
haven't seen before and what they did is
they colored and all of the objects for
us and this is really exciting because
if you look through over the whole
coloring book of the brain after he has
been colored you can just pull out the
structures that the exist and this is an
example of one of those structures
actually to what you see on the right
side are the 3d shapes of
Android and IMAX on the dendrite is blow
the axon is in green you can tell maybe
if you know and suspect the dendrites
have spines that this is a dendrite but
we can actually really confidently say
which part is the next song and which
part ISM is a dendrite from the ear
images take a look on the left what you
see there in green are its back some
time I'm talking about and the reason
why I know it's an axon is if you look
at the little tiny circles that are
inside the green shape those are
vesicles which are fully charged with
neurotransmitter so so you know that
when a nerve impulse surprise these
vesicles will be released and they will
travel through to the blue colored
dendrite you see there is a very tiny
gray region in between that's where the
conjunction between two neurons are so
we can use the e/m images to give the
structures of neurons the deepest which
neurons talk to each other and also the
direction of this of the connection
between the neurons what we don't know
yet and is whether or not we can tell if
a neuron is excitatory or inhibitory and
we really need this type of information
in order to verify the models because
any circuit model really uses
information about excitation and
inhibition in order to do that we're
using the fact that the zebrafish is
transparent animal and it's very easy to
do transgenics with it so we have
labeled the excitatory and inhibitory
neurons and we have imaged them with a
kabocha microscope so what you see here
are three rotating images of the same
animal on the far right you should
recognize the e/m image and on the left
side you see the compose emerges of the
excitatory neurons in magenta and then
give it two years in saya we there of
course many other neurons in the brain
that we have not visualized and but
those who show up as great when we when
we overlay the two images so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to show you the
kombucha star of the animal and I'm
going to overlay it on top of the
electron microscopy
what you will see is that all the
excitatory neurons will be overlaid in
magenta of the inhibitor in years will
be overlaid in cyan and the rest of the
neurons which are brain we do not know
on what kind of general genotype they
have Emily who is really exciting about
being able to do this in the same animal
is we can very confidently say that this
cell we can very confident find a cell
in the pom Poko microscope and the e/m
microscope and tell and this hotels with
all kinds of this so let's take a look
at the images know all these
you
well you just saw was the overlay
between the composer images and the e/m
images now what I'm showing you is it's
a zoom again so you can really see the
cells in the overlap between the two
handsets I have inverted the colors of
the II am such that you can see the
membranes as these each cell as this
white circles and the excitatory
inhibitory neurons are shown in magenta
and in blue what you should see is that
each circle is already colored and you
don't see mixing between the the purple
and the blue colors which means if we
can really confidently say which neuron
is excitatory in which one is inhibitory
then we that all finished thank you so
much thank you for listening and now
back to Florida pool gives some
concluding remarks so you've heard now
and lastly from Mariela how we can
reduce the combination of light
microscopy and electron microscopy to
get a first job and identifying neural
circuits in the novelty professions
brain that are actually doing something
important and use this opportunity to
take up again the question of the
current actin and because that's I think
where we have a complete picture now I
complete problem the fact that fish and
swim against the current are keys along
with my little one that it's important
for them to stay stable in a in a moving
stream the algorithm especially the real
taxes algorithm as you've probably
appreciate that it's not trivial at all
it's a complex computation that if
animal needs to do and involves and
complicated sensory processing and
important computations so it's a
challenging problem and I think we have
for them making headway they there and
if appreciated from Marianas
presentation we even now have a concrete
hypothesis on what elements of neural
circuit elements could be involved and
why connectomics nem pays the circuitry
analysis is really a very useful and
powerful way of constraining and
validating and the circuit models I
think we've sort of come full circle
here with the which this particular
example and I hope it either states what
a powerful technique all of these
approaches manifest and how we can use
the combination of Theory behavioral
imaging calcium imaging and connectomics
to really make an headway in the
question of how a small vertebrate
animals solves an important and adaptive
problem and with that I'm again I'd like
to thank all of the team members who
have them contributed and so
significantly to the whole project and I
would like to thank the or an audience
for for the attention that you've now
standing presentation for additional
panels on the NIH brain initiative view
agenda and our events page and as a
final reminder the panelists will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email thank you again for your
participation